schnee in massen eis und sturm der
winter trifft die mitte deutschlands
aber bis jetzt weniger hart als
befürchtet proteste in myanmar nach dem
putsch begehren zehntausende gegen das
militär auf und könig im eiskanal
francesco friedrich holt im zweierbob
den zehnten wm titel das ist rekord
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zu unserem nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem sonntag die vom sportpark polizei
guten abend alle offenbar haben viele
die unwetterwarnungen ernst genommen
jedenfalls hält sich das befürchtete
chaos in grenzen noch zumindest denn das
extremwetter ist ja noch nicht zu ende
die bisherige bilanz der schnee fiel oft
stundenlang besonders betroffen
westfalen das südliche niedersachsen und
sachsen anhalt aber auch brandenburg und
sachsen dazu jede menge glatteis in
thüringen im nördlichen hessen und in
teilen von nordrhein westfalen und der
winter bleibt erstmal auch in den
nächsten tagen irgendwie so sieht es aus
wenn schnee und sturm die kontrolle über
die straßen gewinnen bei sömmerda
thüringen kapitulieren autofahrer vor
schneeverwehungen
wann kommt der räumdienst ist unterwegs
dreht seine runden doch wirklich
erfolgreich ist fahrer peter huchel
heute nicht so viel schnee zu viel wind
[Musik]
durch nicht
hunderte kilometer landstraßen und
autobahnen viel winter wenig durchkommen
auch im diesigen dortmund eisregen und
schneegestöber sind über das ruhrgebiet
gezogen
die folge busse und manche straßenbahnen
fahren heute nicht auch ganz oben gibt's
probleme wuppertals stolz die
schwebebahn schwebt aber fährt nicht
mehr die stromschiene ist vereist für
uns ein ganz neues phänomen in der
intensität und die fahrzeuge kriegen
leider keinen kontinuierlichen kontakt
zum schiff nach einer guten stunde
befreit die feuerwehr die passagiere
die bahn hat viele züge gar nicht erst
abfahren lassen hannover hauptbahnhof
züge am bahnsteig dienen auch als
wärmestuben es kann dauern
auch morgen wir rechnen damit dass es
den ganzen morgigen tag auf jeden fall
noch schwierig sein wird der vormittag
wenn unsere züge morgens losfahren der
betriebsbeginn der wird nicht so einfach
sein da wird es ein wenig ruckelig der
kampf gegen die unwetter folgen ist noch
lange nicht vorbei auch die lage auf den
autobahnen bleibt unberechenbar und auf
einem rastplatz an der a 7 nahe
hildesheim ist für uns oliver deuker
oliver wie heikel ist das vorankommen
heute naja trotz geschlossener
schneedecke auf den autobahnen und auch
hier auf der a7 geht der verkehr
einigermaßen durch alles sehr langsam
aber er läuft aber es ist auch wirklich
wesentlich weniger fahrzeuge unterwegs
als das dann im normalfall wäre
letztendlich 20 kilometer weiter südlich
sieht schon ein bisschen anders aus
eisen teilstück der a7 bei bockenem
richtung hannover gesperrt
da gibt es das problem mit den
schneeverwehungen rechts und links keine
bäume an den straßen und eine ordnung an
der autobahn und da selbst der wind dann
immer wieder den schnee hin dazu wurde
gesperrt heißt für die leute die
richtung norden wollen die müssen
ausreichend auf die land- und
kreisstraßen und das stück bin ich
selber gefahren das dann schon ein
bisschen chaotisch da gibt es einige
feststecken der lkw also das ist
komplizierter für morgen oder dass die
wetter leute sagen es wird mit
sicherheit noch ein bisschen die nacht
reihen schneiden wie es am morgen
weitergeht weiß er noch nicht ganz genau
heißt aber auf jeden fall dass die leute
die morgen früh in dem verkehr staaten
sollten durchaus auch mal gucken sollten
die räumdienste hoffen wiederum dass sie
in der
nachts wenn da steht dann vielleicht
aufgehört hat die straßen so weit klar
kriegen dass der berufsverkehr am morgen
dann einigermaßen laufen kann
dankeschön oliver deuker war das von der
a 7 ein kurzer blick auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen sie sind weiter rückläufig
allerdings gilt auch heute dass nicht
alle gesundheitsämter am wochenende
daten übermitteln
das robert koch institut meldet 8616
neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 2576 weniger als
vergangenen sonntag
231 menschen sind in verbindung mit 19
gestorben
finanzminister und vizekanzler scholz
ist heute in anderer mission unterwegs
als kanzlerkandidat der sozialdemokraten
berät er zwei tage lang mit seinem
parteivorstand wie die spd in diesem
superwahljahr punkten will
der stopp des klimawandels ist ein
schwerpunkt lassen sagt hat mehr corona
zeiten sind sicher keine guten
wahlkampfzeiten dennoch stimmt sich die
spd auf einen wahlmarathon in diesem
jahr ein und gibt sich selbstbewusst wir
haben einen klaren kurs als partei die
für eine soziale politik steht aber auch
als partei die für technischen
wirtschaftlichen fortschritt steht dafür
dass wir zusätzlich im wohlstand
gewinnen können und zum beispiel eine so
große aufgabe wie den klimawandel
bewältigen können und dass die umfragen
weiter im tief sind scheint den
kanzlerkandidaten nicht zu tangieren und
was uns auch unterscheidet von denen mit
denen wir wettbewerb stehen ist dass wir
führen können die sozialdemokraten
wollen umverteilen kleine und mittlere
einkommen sollen steuerlich entlastet
werden
vermögende dagegen sollen mehr beitragen
gleichzeitig will die spd auch nach der
pandemie kräftig investieren
dazu soll die schuldenbremse ausgesetzt
bleiben an der zukunft ausgerichtet die
politik darf aber nicht die ausnahme
situation eines konjunkturpakets bleiben
ein sparhaushalt wie ihn manche
konservative jetzt einfordern führt uns
nicht aus der krise heraus und führt uns
auch nicht eine gute zukunft inhaltlich
setzt sich die spd damit klar von der
union ab wir haben bock auf diesen
wahlkampf und wir wollen gewählt
regierungsverantwortung tragen und
gleichzeitig den koalitionspartner
angreifen das superwahljahr fordert von
der spd einen politischen spagat nach
myanmar
dort wächst der widerstand gegen den
militärputsch zehntausende gingen trotz
internet blockade auf die straße sie
wollen nicht hinnehmen dass die armee
vor knapp einer woche die macht
übernommen hat das militär behauptet bei
der wahl im november sei betrogen worden
gewonnen hatte die partei von
regierungschef in auggen sun tzu chi
normen odenthal berichtet und plötzlich
fallen schüsse
in der absoluten anspannung weiß keiner
wer wie reagiert die soldaten die
demonstranten die schüsse gehen in die
luft dieses mal noch es sind tausende
heute zehntausende allein auf den
straßen von yang gon myanmars größter
stadt in den vergangenen tagen waren sie
noch zaghaft aber es werden immer mehr
der mut wächst und wer hier unterwegs
ist der braucht mut wir müssen unsere
ängste überwinden ich mache bei dieser
revolution mit der nicht glaube daran
dass die militärdiktatur zusammenbricht
wenn wir zusammenhalten
unsere väter haben gegen das militär
rebelliert wir können jetzt nicht still
halten wir haben bei der wahl für die
demokratie gestimmt jetzt gehen wir auf
die straße gegen die diktatur des
militärs das militär die polizei das
regime zeigt massive präsenz bleibt aber
ruhig immer wieder sind soziale
netzwerke blockiert das internet
abgeschaltet informationen sind wertvoll
was ist mit russland zu che die
regierung führte und jetzt in gewahrsam
ist das heißt sie soll angeklagt werden
die als anwalt geht man davon aus dass
es vor gericht gerechtigkeit gibt aber
sicher ist das nicht
wir hoffen das beste bei rechnen mit dem
schlimmsten wir fordern die sofortige
freilassung sie hat kein gesetz
gebrochen
es brodelt auf den straßen myanmars was
eben friedlich erscheint kann schnell
umschlagen den generälen die sich die
macht griffen sagen gebt sie zurück
im indischen himalaya gebirge ist ein
teil eines gletschers abgebrochen
nach einer massiven flutwelle starben
mindestens sieben menschen 125 werden
noch vermisst
die eismassen stürzten in einen fluss
rissen talabwärts alles mit sich und
beschädigten brücken und zwei
wasserkraftanlagen dutzende mitarbeiter
konnten aus dem schlamm befreit werden
ein ander de wie ist mit 7800 metern der
zweithöchste berg in lienz damit sind
wir bei dir rudi und einem triumphalen
taler für die deutschen bobfahrer platz
1 bis 3 war wirklich klasse deutscher
dreifacherfolg bei der bob wm in
altenberg bronze holt wm debütant hans
peter hennig hofer silber gewinnt
johannes lochner gold geht zum zehnten
mal an francesco friedrich mit
anschieber alexander schüler
er thront über allen francesco friedrich
der zehnte wm-titel
das hat vor ihm noch keiner geschafft
vier läufe viermal bestzeit sein
vorsprung auf johannes lochner mehr als
zwei sekunden eine demonstration der
stärke
leider ohne publikum schade dass niemand
hier sein darf aber trotzdem
wahnsinnsjahr bis jetzt jetzt kommt noch
der vierer und wir freuen uns darauf
auch noch richtig und auch da ist er der
große favorit und rennrodlerin natalie
geisenberger hat mit rang 13 in sankt
moritz zum achten mal den gesamtweltcup
gewonnen erneuter sieg für vincent
geiger in der nordischen kombination
beim heim weltcup in klingenthal
untermauert er seine ansprüche für die
wm in oberstdorf zum fußball eintracht
frankfurt gewinnt in hoffenheim 3 1 und
bleibt tabellenvierter das spiel
bielefeld bremen ist wegen anhaltenden
schneefalls abgesagt worden
55 super bowl finale heute nacht tampa
bay buccaneers gegen die kansas city
chiefs 20.000 zuschauer im stadion
ansteckungsgefahr inbegriffen
trotz pandemie sind fans aus dem ganzen
land nach florida gereist
der super bowl könnte zum super special
event werden
ich habe keine angst wenn du es bekommst
du kommst du
sportlich steht das duell der
quarterback giganten im vordergrund der
sechsmalige champion tom brady gegen den
18 jahre jüngeren patrick mayer
hopstener holmes will vor allem eins
brady irgendwann beerben ein sieg heute
wäre ein schritt in diese richtung
dass hier so viele wie möglich zu
gewinnen und das lied es ja laut der
wettbüros stehen die chancen für den 25
jährigen übrigens ganz gut und für rb
leipzig gibt es jetzt auch einen
austragungsort fürs hinspiel in der
champions league in budapest gegen
liverpool das wollte ich nur sagen es
gab es auch noch nicht
und es drohen das wetter bleibt für
viele eine herausforderung morgen nur
allmählich nachlassen der schneefall im
norden etwas sonne und einzelne schauer
an den küsten schneeverwehungen
höchstwerte minus 11 bis minus ein grad
im südwesten bis plus sechs grad so viel
von uns um viertel vor zehn bringt sie
christian sievers im heute journal auf
den aktuellen stand morgen begrüßt sie
hier petra gerster wir sagen tschüss
wünschen ihnen einen guten start in die
woche und empfehlen jetzt berlin direkt
von chakuza